I've been in engineering and in  advertising okay okay but women don't  want to be engineered actually they do  there's a whole thing no no they don't  because they don't  want to be engineers in college if we  wanted to be an engineer no they're  actually not nurtured to be into stem  and they're not a given up to be in stem  but then why wouldn't you look at the  countries that have more opportunity to  do what we want to do  that  I found it so like like Scandinavian  countries versus like countries in the  Middle East where women have less rights  and it's pretty equal like the pay graph  it increases it doesn't decrease so when  women have more Choice the pay Gap  increase